[Applauso]
tifi finire come andiamo mourinho
ciao ragazzi noi intorno a te ora tocca
a noi risolvere l'ultimo indovinello e
poi potremo finalmente uscire da queste
skyroom ma poi penso che ci aspetterà
qualcos'altro
cioè una battaglia lasero una sorta di
battaglia con premi grazie al sacco per
le risposte che avete dato per l'ultimo
indovinello un sacco di risposte mi
sembravano giuste ma se n'è una che mi
sembra perfetta è tuo ma lozano più gli
altri mi avete scritto un sacco di cose
e vi ringrazio altrimenti da sola non so
se ci sarei mai arrivata
ma la risposta che più mi ha colpito è
il nome perché se ci pensate
il nome e tu e il tuo nome ma lo usano
più gli altri perché gli altri si
chiamano tu non chiami te stesso
anzi il proprio nome non si dice quasi
mai invece gli altri lo usano tantissimo
perché marty quindi penso che sia la
risposta giusta
spero altrimenti brucerò l'ultima
possibilità di uscire da queste scape
room
ora proviamo a scrivere la risposta e
vediamo cosa succede siete pronti
andiamo a mettere la risposta adesso
scriviamo il nome
avete sentito c'è stato il rumore come
di una porta che si sbloccava vediamo se
è apparso qualcosa qua quasi la mia
risposta c'è ancora l'indovinello ho
sentito un rumore ma ma non è successo
niente sono ancora chissà quando entrò
forse devo mettere il fucile laser prima
proviamo indossare i fucili laser poi
prova a spingere questa porta vediamo se
riesco uscire
eccola qua non so come si mette forse
questo vado avanti
proviamo
[Musica]
ok forse ci sono riuscita
ecco fatto ce l'ho fatta
ecco per paro il fucile laser casomai
granny sia proprio qua fuori tanti
andiamo provo a spingere questa porta no
è bloccata non succede niente mi fai
naso linea
provo a sparare con il fucile duster si
[Musica]
cazzi successo qualcosa sia bello guarda
ti lascia una luce blu ma sia aperto
posso finalmente uscire dal game room
non ci posso credere
devo comunque fare silenzio per i tre ma
usciamo adesso vediamo dove siamo
e sono uscita ce l'ho fatta guardate non
capisco se treni potrebbe essere qua
intorno estate può fare forse c'è
qualche indovinello che non risolto ma
l'importante è che ora sono uscita ora
prova a uscire da qualche porta e
vediamo che succede è tornata ai ragazzi
cioè non completamente
ma c'è un po di luce per fortuna così
almeno vedo dove sto andando comunque
proverò a scappare da quella porta
vediamo che succede della sicurezza
[Musica]
ritardi ciao ciao mimmo minuto anche un
modo per aiutare t3i nubi qua c così
posso scrivere berlino sentito il rumore
graziani non riesco a capire tu fai
premi
[Musica]
nella pancia
[Applauso]
[Musica]
ascoltiamoci nasconditi il treno merci o
in 3d mai quasi lavoro io controllo con
l'uscita di aido non si mangia la
ragnatela sparato di nuovo ma sentite mi
ha già colpito due volte non so quante
vite o non riesco a ricaricare come si
fa
sembra di non aver colpito
ora posso colpirla
beh inutile in d'armi maledizione non
l'ho colpita neanche un po l'evento ha
colpito due volte davanti e può
ricaricare la signorina maledetta
compito
ma sicuro berlino potreste darmi invece
di non chiare le corse ciao finite colpi
ma non è anche un mito nel vino
proteggimi con il tuo severino bonomi ha
colpito di nuovo e rosso
avete visto
prendi a insegnare rosso fra quindi
fosse non mi ha beccato di nuovo giallo
sta distruggendo lo ski promo può
ricalcare menti non stai attento non
distruggere niente questo è l'unico modo
in cui possiamo difenderci da tre anni
per caricare sposare ho paura che ho già
detto l'ho già la cosa sembra l'unico
rifugio resto perché esteri gare
ok si è caricato far fortuna marie lovey
il pericoloso 6.000 dietro berlino
uno mi ha colpito come posso colpirmi
tramite il cartone è crollata cazzo
guardate o pochissimi vita intorno
merlino sta distruggendo tutte state
room
io mi torna ad avere offerto i colpi non
so se l'ho beccata a casa distruggendo
tutto berlino todi pg
[Musica]
figli come è finita qua è crollato tutto
avevo visto i corpi devo uscire fuori da
qua sono intrappolata qua dentro
nuovamente è meglio che scappo
[Musica]
bene io premio così potrò colpirla nel
meglio perché sei tornado anche tutti i
gremi perché non c'era più
[Musica]
non è sì penso devo baciare i genitori
ma niente nobili due corpi ok
aiutami giardino no devi distrarre credi
che vissuto tutto non so da dove il sì è
ora stato visto e sparando
ma verissima ti faccio vedere gli eventi
fai premi sparito marinosci a cercarla
così abbiamo un momento di tregua
nel frattempo quale quasi tutto
distrutto ha distrutto tutto premi e
berlino berlino non prende il fucile è
l'unica mia difesa
fate casino spa di successo tutto è
felicissimo di distruggere bruzzo questa
marino questa è la nostra unica difesa
la mostra trincea nate ieri molti delle
cose e fontane deve distrarre grevi
capito se ti distrai g io potrò colpirla
più volte così finalmente possiamo
sconfiggerla mi stai ascoltando facciamo
così tu vai da grandi faida esca
e poi io la cantino cosa ne pensi non
capisco se berlino mi ascolta davvero o
fa finta di niente
qua è crollata anche una miccia berlino
ascoltati bene questo è l'unico piano
che può funzionare ma e tira di
distruggere tutto può funzionare questo
piano altrimenti potremmo rimanere
chiusi qua per sempre
anzi no perché distrutto tutto ma la sua
posizione rock e non può proprio fare
video su youtube marino
così tanto rumore fate io inizio a
uscire da qua e veduto che può essere
treni tu continua pure a fare l'amore
così magari lei viene da quattro ok
ragazzi cui siamo fuori da qui
berlino sta continuando a distruggere
tutto ma se non esco fuori da qua
rimango intrappolata ancora una volta
con attento
cercherò di nascondermi dietro le
scatole così premier umilmente e devi
finire con me
cantiamo marino
[Applauso]
[Musica]
forse son riuscito a sconfiggerla perché
sia passato avete visto antico un
fighter
maledetto visto non importiamo peccati
questo sono in giallo su per fini non
esiste
non capisco se i rumori li sta facendo
grandi un bambino
[Musica]
eccole l'avviato
o no
[Musica]
ieri
[Applauso]
ma berlino aiuta mi vedo più è andata
via
marino aiuta mentre parla berlino
maledetta
[Musica]
ma adesso
tesi
e sul fatto capire di preferire ho
trovato un'ottima difesa o uno scudo
personale ha detto vediamo segreti
riesce a bocca millesi ok ragazzi ho
recuperato una vita sei treni non mi
colpisce per molto tempo recupero la
vita almeno una nel recupero non lo
stesso anche lì scappiamo da qui può
allontanarmi da qua rifiutare di seguire
la regola del piano che ti ho detto
altrimenti non riuscirò mai a
sconfiggere credimi strada non so se
berlino ha capito il piano all'ostaia
voci male leggere news
[Musica]
mi sono detto perché non ho mai corpi
caricati
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì mi fido giovani pieni di regali
[Applauso]
[Musica]
beh
cioè
[Applauso]
il piano
ora questa crisi
ci sei cambiata di avermi soffitto è e
invece no berlino è riuscito a fare il
piano perfetto e cioè sia distretto
brino è riuscito a farle credere che mi
aveva colpito che invece poi ci sei o da
sotto e la staffetta e ora pecca di
questo o no è ancora viva a spendere
vuoi scaricare o no
vedrete
[Musica]
per ora g scomparso spero che sia
scomparsa per sempre non che ritorni
siamo riusciti dell'approccio anch'io
non so di un bel mi piace se volete
vedere un'altra avventura
io il merlino e non lo so chi non
sussisterà nella prossima avventura e se
volete rivivere l'avventura ricordate
gli episodi dall'episodio il numero uno
e vediamo se trovate qualcosa di cui non
vi eravate accorti e ora vi lascio fa 4
castellino su cui cliccare per non dare
ai nostri altri video cliccate su quella
che preferite e voi la missione
[Musica]